E aí
e eu conheço pessoas estressadas
ansiosas deprimidas e muito irritadas
confessa em que muitas vezes me vejo
assim também e quando estamos
emocionalmente
afetados não somos uma boa companhia
isso impacta na qualidade das relações
e eu acredito que relacionamentos
saudáveis
pedem elegância existencial eu nasci na
metade da década de 70 e íntegro uma
geração de pessoas que viveu o começo da
livre expressão hoje tão presente
potencializada nas relações
modelo de relacionamento entre as
pessoas passou por muitas transformações
antes a gente se divide em grupinhos
tinha turma do vôlei a Turma do Pagode A
Turma da mobilete os bancos dos darques
os bagunceiros As Patricinhas e assim
foi na minha adolescência hoje às as
mães estão em rede e se conectam
virtualmente você clica e se torna amigo
ficou instantâneo estamos mergulhados na
Matrix da tecnologia que rompeu
Barreiras do tempo e do espaço nos
conectando com o mundo digital o nosso
jeito de viver mudou bastante o Brasil
está entre os cinco países com maior
número de usuários da internet ficando
Inclusive a frente da Rússia no Japão da
Alemanha e até do Reino Unido e essa
soberania se acentuou ainda mais durante
a pandemia do covid-19 no último
mapeamento de hábitos dos internautas o
Brasil ele ficou em segundo segundo
lugar no ranking mundial Como o povo
mais conectado os brasileiros passam em
média 10 horas
conectados em aplicativos extremense
sites redes sociais pé as penas se nós
considerarmos a recomendação médica de
dormir entre sete e oito horas por noite
para cuidar da nossa saúde poderíamos
considerar que hoje em dia estamos
passando quase metade do Nosso Tempo
Acordado na internet e a internet ela
ampliou as relações de um jeito que eu
jamais imaginaria mas algo aqui merece a
nossa atenção
as pessoas estão muito mais muito
solitárias porque interagir com centenas
de conhecidos e desconhecidos numa rede
social não significa companhia o mesmo
que não significa que nós pertencemos de
fato na vida dessas pessoas entende isso
é muito superficial e eu você nós já
manipulamos pelo menos uma dúzia de
vezes mensagens postadas nas redes
sociais pelo simples desejo de
hoje nós queremos que os outros saibam
não é verdade e ficamos ali só
monitorando as curtidas que é uma
espécie de aplauso virtual que afaga o
nosso ego quantos de nós já camuflou a
nossa própria Essence para se enquadrar
ele não para deu midiático ou dado pela
estética pela moda aquele status
profissional e até mesmo por aquela
autoimagem empoderada só que o título de
ser humano online tem o seu preço né as
facilidades é claro que elas são
inúmeras envolvem mandar mensagem
instantânea pelo WhatsApp pagar o boleto
do colégio 2clix rastrear uma compra
encomendar um jantar chamado transporte
enviar um pixel amigo muitas
possibilidades porém existem um ônibus
também eu diria que nós ficamos mais
ansiosos em e
agitados estressados também E o pior
superficiais iludidos é isso mesmo
superficiais porque os relacionamentos à
distância
eles perdem o calor da convivência real
com seus amores e dissabores
estamos iludidos porque até os mais
experientes acabam acreditando que tudo
que é visto é verdadeiro gente nós
acabamos ignorando que o sorriso aquele
bonito que a gente se Encanta ele foi
ensaiado várias vezes para a capital
melhor ângulo na foto e outra quem
acorda com o pijama lisinho meu cabelo
alinhado né você da mesma possível
aquele apartamento arrumadinho com dois
filhos pequeno cachorrinho morando lá
Olá tudo isso cria uma linha imaginária
dividindo os perfeitos e os outros os
privilegiados e os infelizes
parece que nós estamos perdendo sabe o
senso da realidade estamos sendo
engolidos por padrões de ostentação e de
perfeição e quanto mais expostos ao
mundo ilusório que a maioria se fossem
mostrar nas redes sociais mais surgem
relatos de pessoas emocionalmente
adormecidas porque diante de tanta
exposição as cenas montadas passa o
absorvê-las como verdadeiras e distantes
do próprio mundo querem o mundo
perfeitinho do ciclano e beltrano e
quando não possuem sabe que acontece se
deprimem se entristece como se fossem
excluídos do sistema mas não são apenas
acreditam se e não se trata de algo que
começou hoje o veio de ontem para hoje
não isso tudo veio a conta é
uma proteção aqui uma invejinha ali e
começaram a parecida seus doentes o
Brasil tem 16 milhões de pessoas
sofrendo com depressão e sabe qual a
principal reclamação dos definidos eles
lamentam o sentimento de vazio e de
solidão
E por quê Porque milhares de pessoas se
sentem sozinhas mesmo tendo centenas de
amigos no Facebook no Instagram
é porque a popularidade de curtidas
imediatas no pulso do restaurante não
satisfaz a fome de afeto a resposta para
mim é que está faltando e empatia
ninguém ninguém é empático olhando para
tela do smartphone é preciso conviver
com os amigos está com a família sentir
que as pessoas se importam com você e
isso isso depende do velho delicioso o
Olho no Olho é assim que se constroem
relações reais
aproximação virtual não é a mesma coisa
porque é superficial e a empatia gente
como é algo simples a muitos falsos
empáticos por aí muita gente confunde
empatia com dar conselho fazer caridade
achando que sabe o que é melhor para o
outro
e como praticar empatia e humanizar as
relações
se o wi-fi rede 4G
aplicativos e um bom smartphone é
escolhido ou são escolhidos como gênero
de primeira necessidade
empatia é habilidade de perceber o outro
sabe de respeitar quem ele é é querer
estar com ele ouvir o que ele tem a
dizer mais ouvir de verdade sem
interromper ficar por perto sem
interferir
Nós precisamos trabalhar a nossa
elegância existencial sabe isso
significa entender primeiramente quem eu
sou como eu me sinto como é que eu posso
contribuir com relacionamentos saudáveis
a ser um bom ouvinte ser alguém disposto
a servir e principalmente abrir mão do
julgamento
imagina que tá ali passando uma
criancinha perto de você e ela tropeçou
na sua frente caiu machucou joelhinho Na
tentativa de consolar sabe o que
acontece muitas vezes nós diz
qualificamos a dor da criança sabe de
que maneira dizendo assim levanta isso
não é nada vai passar quando você casar
Sara gente
isso é uma afirmação arrogante demais e
que desmerece a dor do outro e dor dói
se dor dói e eu não posso usar uma frase
para padrão que não expressa um
reconhecimento de que machucar o joelho
incomoda de verdade
de que a intensidade da dor varia de
pessoa para pessoa
quando nós somos simpáticos nós nos
esforçamos
Ah entendi que o outro tá sentindo sem
estabelecer ali um certo e errado
segundo a nossa visão e se você deseja
trazer a elegância da empatia para sua
personalidade eu te convido a eliminar
os rótulos Eu sei eu sei que rotular é
algo quase viciante né mas nós
precisamos parar com isso aí ele é legal
um era muito chata que cara mais
esquisito
nossa ela é uma mentirosa
tudo isso interpretação é como eu me
sinto diante da pessoa diante da
situação você você já deve ter sido
outro lado alguma vez como é que você se
sentiram a interpretação do outro
revelou quem você verdadeiramente é pois
é precisamos refletir sobre essas coisas
eu me lembro e quando eu fui para o
ensino médio em um colégio
particular como bolsista Eu vim da
comunidade para preencher uma vaga de
poucas vagas com desconto na escola que
foi montada por empresários que tinha o
desejo de oferecer aos seus filhos uma
educação diferenciada
foi uma experiência assim intensa e uma
jovem de 14 anos que até aquela idade
não tinha tido nenhum tênis de marca
famosa por exemplo eu estava convivendo
com pessoas de uma realidade muito
diferente da minha isso era assim
escancarado eu ainda não sabia que era
viajar de avião morar numa casa própria
e não ter a tu visse vestir ali um
moletom que custava 3 dígitos e eu
poderia ter acolhido o rótulo de
bolsista elevado isso para a vida toda
ou seja ser aquela pessoa que venceria
na vida se lhe dessem um desconto se lhe
doassem o material e que convivesse sob
constante ameaça seja obediente aos
padrões
mas mas eu escolhi seguir apenas comigo
mesma não era bolsista do colégio Top
também não era aluna mediana em
matemática
eu escolhi colecionar as minhas próprias
credenciais
assumir papéis na carreira como
jornalista terapeuta empresária e tudo
que eu fiz foi aproveitada as
possibilidades de reconhecer que eu não
precisava ter credenciais definitivas
tudo bem que eu sou complexa e tudo bem
que você também é as relações humanas
são ricas exatamente por nós somos
diferentes em constante mudança porém
porém gente nós precisamos entender como
funcionamos para que a gente seja mais
leve uma companhia agradável um
profissional competente uma pessoa
essencial para alguém ao escolher é
elegância como ser humano Nós aprendemos
a ser leve ou pesado E aprendemos que
ser leve ou pesado é uma questão de
escolha e aqui eu não me refiro aos
excessos da Gula tá são os exageros que
pesam sobre nós por conta do orgulho da
vaidade do egoísmo da Posse que temos
sobre o outro da falta de amor-próprio e
até mesmo da falta de fé no melhor o
vale ainda dizer que leveza na vida não
significa ausência de problemas Ok temos
capacidade de lidar com situações
desagradáveis sem nos vestir de roupa de
vítima sem usar a roupa de vítima sempre
que algo ruim pelo amor de Deus ai algo
ali a ser aprendido ali um aprendizado e
quando as coisas complicam escolha ser
elegante de valores resistência afaste
Afaste o mau humor e tristeza
se você precisar respirar fundo 10 vezes
2050 às vezes e outra se a sua aparência
não tá legal coloca uma roupa boa usa um
delicioso perfume dela de sua pele e
vitaliza a sua alma
escolha ser gentil
especialmente com você mesmo se cuide
Cuide da sua personalidade agradável
sabe o que vai acontecer você será uma
Expert na arte de lidar com pessoas
e eu desejo que esteja na sua lista
de prioridades
trazer a empatia para os seus olhos os
seus ouvidos e as suas atitudes
e da
transbordar elegância saindo você mesmo
sabe por quê que será real porque não
será um edifício virtual uma montagem
para conquistar clientes nas redes
sociais
persista tá bom siga seu caminho com bom
ânimo e eu te digo sorria sorria com o
coração sem rótulos nem posições
eu te convido assim
elegantemente você